I never even got to go to comic-con as a
fan I was already a professional the
first time I came here I grew up reading
about it I grew up in Jersey so this is
on the other side of the country and
even back then before it was what we all
know it as that modern-day can film
festival in America end or Sundance
amped up it used to just be like a big
comic book convention that you heard
about mecca for a hardcore fan so when I
first came here is 95 we came with mall
rats and we screened it here and if you
were ever going to screen a movie called
mall rats about dudes who love comic
books anywhere in the world and feel
successful it was right here in the
crotch of comic-con we went to the
horton plaza screened the flick it was a
packed house free screening but as a
packed house and they went nuts like the
the universal execs came up to me
afterwards like this can be bigger an
animal house man is huge based on that
reaction and the fact of the matter is
like that audience that saw it in comic
con at that point in time 1995 that was
it that was anyone who would ever really
care about it that much it wouldn't be
for a few years until suddenly that
movie works more you know or feels like
it's weird when people talk about seeing
that movie now he talks like a 15 year
old and there's just like all Brody's my
life I'm like that's so strange hey you
were come when we made that and be
there's like when we made that he was
the anti-hero he was like people be like
you don't know anyone like that dude is
like oh god yeah me and my friends and
now he is the mainstream Brody is kind
of like what a hundred and twenty
thousand Brody's out there and they're
all dancing isn't that weird they found
the place for themselves a little place
for us what I like though is I got in on
the ground early i was doing it could
just because i liked it like comic books
and crap like that from 95 on so now in
2012 and should even go i'm back like to
you know 2009 forward suddenly it was
like do you know as every hack
journalist on the planet rides the geeks
of inherited the earth and suddenly
everything that i was into became
popular and so that positioned me here
fantastic you know what I'm saying like
I went is this is sad but imagine it
time 1995-96 where I'm the biggest act
at comic-con you know like oh he made
Mallrats made no money but there is now
throw a rock and you hit a celebrity's
crazy how many town cars roll up and
down and people come in jump up on stage
Hall age go like come see the next movie
and then get the out of town but it
creates a lot of congestion and whatnot
so it is a little different from when I
first got out here now it's more of a
multimedia extravaganza back then hard
hardcore combo convention then the movie
studios moved in the gamers were always
kind of there but now it's just like as
you see the banners you come into town a
celebration of the popular arts that
covers everything broad that
road 50 shades of grey is coming what's
that have to do with comic books you
know what I'm saying but everything
counts here like it's kind of like you
know what in the pretty in pink I think
it was or yeah I want to say it's pretty
pic even they did in clueless is that
once seen in the beginning we're like
here's the jocks man and here's the this
brains and here's the stoners here's the
geeks in the outcasts you know the geeks
in the outcasts now take over this town
to the tune of over 100 k and when you
have that many outcasts you are you're
the cast you ain't out anymore you're
the end cash your front and center so I
don't know it's good time to be a geek
but I never considered myself like I'm
emeritus but no I just been lucky enough
to be here since 95 and so that gives
you some it gives you real estate like I
keep waiting every year for them to go
you're very sweet but like Hall H
belongs to movies and people that do
things all the time you haven't done
anything since 94 like get off the stage
but every year they're like you coming
to close on saturday night I'm like hell
yeah that as long as I get that call
I'll always feel relevant in this world
but but like a godfather hell no just a
big old booster my interest in the next
few years and it's kind of selfish is
just erasing these hard strict lines
between the mediums particularly TV film
and Internet I thought about it long and
hard my I'm like the lawnmower man once
i get online I'm God there but anywhere
else man though like did you get thrown
off
playing for being fat like I know you
from somewhere I don't have enough juice
like if i could if i can move anyone
anywhere it's going to be online and i
can mobilize people online to do things
in the real world a little bit but it's
much easier to just keep them where they
are so it's one thing to be like you
know to tweet out hey man I'm coming to
do a show and in a Portland or something
like that me and Moe's you're going to
portland oregon you got like a month and
a half to kind of hope that people see
that and maybe come out it's a whole
completely different beast when you're
like here's the show watch it and people
go where is this is this just an online
show because you know it's on it lives
on their laptop at first where their
iphones and then you go wow looks it has
a production value of a show show so I
don't know it is a cow's online show and
then just like yesterday hulu sold the
show up north and canada to space one of
their networks so suddenly it's yeah
it's an online show but it's also a TV
show like get rid of that line like I
can't stand that when you meet people
and like oh that's an online show it's
like it's show man wherever you watch
it's where you watch it and I tested
that theory with my kid before we
started doing spoilers for hulu I was
like hey man I'm like she watches a lot
of media now she's a TV for raesha
Stevie watch her in my wife so I'm like
you watch modern family what networks
that on she's like Hulu I'm like there
it is she don't know from ABC CBS she
goes to one place that puts all the
content and she picks and chooses from
it so at that point there's no longer
like hey man I'm doing a TV show which
is a TV show cuz it's official at one of
the three recognized networks now there
are all these other doors and used to be
three roads in now anything counts and
for me the next year I just want to keep
kind of bringing down that barrier
between one and the other and I just
went where my strengths are their
greatest like online so if I have a
chance at moving the needle whatsoever
on a show it's going to be on a web
based show or show that has a big web
component where I could just tweet tune
in now ask a question blah blah blah if
it's just me dryly trying to reach
television then they've got to spend a
lot of money to get people there day one
so for me I'm like this seems like an
awesome back door and once you get in
the room kick down a wall and
expand the room for yourself and that's
what indie film is right now like back
when I was a kid it was all about okay
you may get you sell it to someone else
your dreams come true which I always
hated like as an independent artist I
was independent once when I made clerks
after that miramax had everything like
somebody else was always like here's
your money kit so there was no real
independence like you know you were
suddenly in business with somebody they
were paying you're over there paying
your bills there's now this kind of
newfound independence we're so long as
you're not just focusing on one thing
and who could do that anymore you'll
starve I mean if you're filming you
wanna be a filmmaker in your like I'm
gonna live off Megan films Chris Nolan
lives off mega films and so is Mari
Scorsese and Clint Eastwood Spielberg
the rest of us we don't live off it it's
just something that we do you should
spin as many plates as possible like
because one day they don't let you make
films anymore like I want to check out
of a party before these cats were like
we're done with you so I was like you
know I'm gonna go over here and figure
out some fun stuff to do so indie
filmmakers now they have the technology
is democratized the medium so anybody
can make a flick used to be after rent a
16-millimeter camera crap you take your
iPhone you can shoot it you cut it on
your eye friend you could upload it to
YouTube distribution you can be done
with the entire process in a month you
know how they always say like see this
room these are the computers that
launched the first rocket and now it
fits in your hands same thing like all
that crap we went through to make clerks
you could do right on your iPhone
problem is everybody could do the same
thing now we're all amazing little
content generators with our own stories
to tell so you've got a lot more
competition you used to be like I stood
out if I was trying right now clerks
never would happen people been like you
see that movie was terrible oh yeah
there's dark night so I started at a
time where there wasn't a ton of
competition like when i submitted to
sunday as the clerks six hundred films
and we were one of 14 and that was like
a nail-biter do you know how many submit
now thousands how do you get to that so
there's so much more competition and
things balanced out though in the way it
used to be harder for us to find
distribution now you don't need anybody
to distribute you make your art you
distribute yourself but you're not gonna
have the bang zoom of like here's a
billboard here's the TV commercial
here's that you don't need that crap
though
I'm saying that's bells and whistles and
it's fun and if you have the money and
you feel like reaching a massive
audience then spend on marketing but in
the world of online man you've already
got an audience here just shift them
over here shift them over here shift
them over here as long as you keep it
free from there all kind of come back
what happens at comic-con is just sad